alors je vais pas
répéter la la Une de Libye ce matin
qu'il est qualifie d'apprentis
on a l'impression qu'il
de beaucoup de
moins compétent c'est peut-être fort
mais de méconnaissance de l'économie oui
Laurence Parisot demande au gouvernement
de prendre en compte le principe de
réalité il y a un malaise on est on
n'est pas dans la même réalité
gouvernement entrepreneuriat
j'étais venu me m'exprimer sur ce
plateau sur l'université on avait vu le
premier ministre on avait vu le ministre
du Sport productif qui nous ont fait un
show d'ailleurs qui nous aimait qui
serait attentif à ce que nous voulons
qu'il voulait des entreprises prospèrent
très bien droites et je vous disais dont
acte nous verrons bien
aujourd'hui
une des mesures phares du premier loi de
finances c'est quand même d'aligner la
fiscalité du capital sur ceux du travail
là ça procède d'une méconnaissance de
l'économie totale des choses comme ça ça
nous laisse pantois et d'ailleurs ça a
provoqué une réaction historique
l'ensemble de ces de ces mouvements qui
sont pas toujours ensemble dans toutes
les actions à l'exception de la CGPME
d'ailleurs notoire
ont tous aussi à l'initiative des
pigeons qui ont lancé cela
leur accord alors désaccord disons le
raccord sur le désaccord on va y revenir
sur ce mouvement des pigeons dont vous
parliez je voulais d'abord vous
interpeler sur ce rapport en ce rapport
sur la compétitivité qui sera dévoilée
dans son intégralité lundi d'ailleurs
lundi prochain c'est Pierre Gallois l'ex
patron de ADS ce qui en est l'auteur et
qui proposerait notamment 30 milliards
d'allongements de cotisations sociales
sur deux ou trois ans est-ce que ce
genre de mesure peut permettre le choc
de compétitivité dont parle Laurence
Parisot bien évidemment
ça fait longtemps c'est un de nos
chevaux de bataille nous réclamons une
allègement nos cotisations pour nous
avons un des taux des prélèvements les
plus importants d'Europe et si on veut
redonner la complexité des entreprises
et bien effectivement il faut alléger
les prélèvements et Laurence Parisot
parle aussi de compétitivité
ne savent pas
à quelle sauce ils vont être mangés
en plus on nous parle de mesure qui sont
maintenant rétroactives
dans quelle décision prendre quelle est
la bonne décision aujourd'hui
quelques si demain tout son plan tout ce
qu'il a bâti peut-être détruit
et de façon rétroactive donc il y a
quand même pour nous une très grande
insécurité
prélèvements tout à l'heure concrètement
votre réalité c'est quoi dans votre
entreprise comment ça fonctionne un coût
du travail aujourd'hui tiens on va
prendre quelque chose de très très
simple l'exonération des heures
supplémentaires on en avait parlé aussi
ici
quand on va prendre du concret quand la
mesure a été votée lors du précédent de
la stature
en tant que chef d'entreprise je ne me
suis pas posé une seule question en
disant je vais faire travailler plus
j'ai mis en place mais je n'ai pas
demandé en contrepartie des heures de
travail parce qu'il y a oublie souvent
nos gouvernants c'est la productivité et
mes employés m'ont donné la productivité
lors quand on a supprimé ces heures de
travail fiscalité fiscalité j'ai pas
embauché j'ai simplement
je suis au bout du jour j'ai supprimé
cette exonération je suis pris 16 heures
de 16h supplémentaires ça a pas créé un
seul emploi et salut comme conséquence
pour des employés qu'il y aillent à peu
près la première journée
par mois ça a une conséquence de
puissant à 1000 euros par an donc c'est
pas neutre donc c'est de l'argent qui ne
sera pas investi c'est la baisse de
pouvoir d'achat voilà et comment ça a
été accueilli par les salariés justement
comment ils l'ont vécu très mal très mal
très mal bien évidemment alors bon si je
prends mon cas personnel moi je suis une
PME de 43 personnes j'ai un rapport très
direct avec les collaborateurs et
je dois me gratifier d'avoir une
excellente équipe c'est absolument
l'entreprise réussisse grâce à eux donc
j'ai moi-même mis en place des mesures
correctives avec la plupart justement
sur la productivité des mesures
d'objectif pour arriver à essayer de
compenser ces mesures mais c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait la cassure entre
entre le monde aujourd'hui politique qui
nous dirige et qui ont l'impression
qu'il ne comprennent pas nos réalités
alors que sur le terrain patron je parle
des PME sur tous les pays dont je suis
et salarié sont accords ensemble et
mettre en place des mesures pour arriver
à continuer
c'est ce qui se met je suis pas à
Carrare c'est ce qui fait dans beaucoup
d'entreprises on a vraiment eu comme
vous le dites il y a un flou autour de
la réalité des chefs d'entreprise des
chefs de PME et puis et puis les
gouvernants alors on parlait de la
compétitivité justement le rapport n'est
pas encore sorti mais déjà on entend que
il ne sera sûrement pas on s'en inspire
rarement pas au niveau du gouvernement
ces mesures là d'ailleurs avec lesquels
vous êtes plutôt en accord qui sont
proposés par Pierre pierre Gallois on va
écouter les cinq continents on est allé
leur demander comment rendre compétitif
les entreprises
sur le sujet là
compétitivité des entreprises
je pense qu'on peut jouer sur la sur la
TVA et puis jouer sur comment s'appelle
les entreprises qui travaillent sur
l'exportation j'ai aucune idée parce que
honnêtement c'est une question piège là
je sais pas moi peut-être
il y a guerre comme par la BU pub de la
connaissance non
je pense qu'il y a un problème de coût
du travail
maintenant le coût du travail est-ce
qu'il faut payer les gens à 500 euros
par mois pour qu'on soit compétitif par
rapport au pays asiatiques je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas je ne serai pas vous
répondre même les économistes ont du mal
à nous répondre alors petit citoyen je
vais avoir du mal à vous dire
honnêtement et vous donner surtout la
solution bonsoir
je veux pas d'autres solutions puis en
faisant travailler davantage les
Français puis c'est 35 heures c'est pas
suffisant
est-ce qu'il y a des solutions je vois
que vous prenez des notes il y a deux
choses qui m'ont intéressés il y a deux
réflexions qui m'ont intéressées alors
un intervenants disaient la TVA bon
c'est pas nouveau je vais déjà expliquer
ce plateau le Medef avait proposé une
mesure qu'on appelait la double hélice
c'était un augmentation de la TVA contre
baisse des charges sociales déjà pas
trop mal plutôt et augmentation de
l'assiette la CSG sur les revenus du
capital contre baisse des charges
salariales c'est à dire que ce que le
l'employé allait perdre au pouvoir
d'achat en hausse et le gagner en
salaire net et on avait calculé que ça
faisait un gain je crois pour un SMIC de
je vais vous dire des bêtises mais ça
faisait un gars réel donc oui c'est une
bonne idée TVA contre quelque chose
contre les charges sociales
CSG contre la fiscalité et également
alors ce monsieur qui disait ce qu'il
faut payer les ouvriers 500 euros par
mois il parle de coût du travail il a
pas de raison qu'on dit que du travail
mais il est pas question payer les
ouvriers 500 euros par mois par mois ce
qu'on attaque c'est les charges sociales
c'est pas de baisser le salaire des gens
c'est il y a deux choses c'est
flexibilité pour les entreprises
flexibilité c'est un test un gros mot
c'est un gros mot la possibilité pour
pour le patron de licencié du jour au
lendemain son salarié alors c'est ça je
dirais que c'est du
Guignols un chef d'entreprise le but
d'un seul entreprises c'est alors c'est
pas c'est pas l'emploi mais se
développer son entreprise donc
développer son entreprise quand on
développe son entreprise on crée de
l'emploi on crée de l'emploi
nécessairement créer de l'emploi c'est
une c'est pas une c'est une conséquence
c'est pas une fille c'est une
conséquence et je ne connais pas de chef
d'entreprise qui soit heureux licenciés
ou alors il y a peut-être quelques
malades qui achètent quelque part mais
cela je les connais pas je l'ai
rencontré pas en plus quand on dit
flexibilité
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
faut dans des moments de crise une
entreprise a besoin sa masse sa masse
salariale et pour préserver les emplois
de tous enfin du plus grand nombre il
est peut-être nécessaire d'utiliser
justement pas sauvages c'est pas le
patron qui décidera tout seul
directement sur des accords qu'on
négocie qui sont cadrés mais la
flexibilité est importante oui on voit
qu'il y a toute une réflexion autour de
comment finalement relancer toute cette
activité économique hier soir on était
au siège de la CGPME à Rambouillet la
CPME des Yvelines la Confédération
Générale du patronat des petites et
moyennes entreprises qui organisaient
une réunion justement pour informer ses
membres sur un petit peu les mesures
gouvernementales leur donner un
éclairage et nous avons recuqué le
témoignage de deux chefs de PME et on
écoute leurs inquiétudes
Patricia la rivière et Jean-Baptiste
armée son chef de deux jeunes PME dans
un contexte de crise et alors que de
nouvelles réformes sont en cours comment
tirer son épingle du jeu la CGPME des
Yvelines a donc organisé une réunion
pour éclairer ses membres sur les
dispositions gouvernementales à venir et
c'est important qu'ils en échangent
effectivement parce qu'on en a des
choses à dire surtout vis-à-vis des
événements qui se passent en ce moment
des lois qui vont être décidées qui vont
être mises en place on a besoin de
réagir et de de s'exprimer ils habitent
ça la compétitivité nous on a simplement
une problématique de prix je veux dire
les prix tombent de plus en plus la
deuxième problématique c'est que on est
beaucoup on commence à attaquer beaucoup
par les pays de l'Est
donc qui ont des coûts entre 4 et 6 fois
moins cher que nous et qui viennent sur
le marché français pour vendre dans
l'impression grand format avec les
systèmes UPS avec ce genre de choses ils
arrivent à des délais très courts la
qualité quasiment la même sauf que ils
ont une main d'oeuvre qui est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup moins cher que nous on
a tous les mêmes machines donc forcément
on veut tous faire tourner des machines
donc forcément le marché diminue les
prix se cassent un peu la figure
mais bon il suffit de se battre quoi de
trouver des nouveaux marchés des
nouvelles niches et on arrive à s'en
sortir outre la compétitivité toujours
ce problème récurrent la relation avec
les banques qui conditionnent la
trésorerie des entreprises le contact
avec les banques est extrêmement
difficile et le contact avec les
assureurs aussi sont extrêmement
difficiles moi j'entends des gros des
grands discours et sur le terrain je ne
vois pas ce qui est dit dans les grands
discours notamment vis-à-vis des banques
vis-à-vis des administrations la
simplification elle est pas encore en
place d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que mes
clients sont un peu débordés parmi les
réformes en cours qui font des bas le
projet de loi de finances 2013 il était
notamment prévu une hausse de la
taxation des sessions immobilières
passant de 19% aujourd'hui après de 60%
après une très forte mobilisation de la
CGPME et des autres syndicats patronaux
la proposition du gouvernement a
finalement été abandonnée
vous êtes président du Medef dans les
Yvelines on vient de l'entendre ce
projet de loi de finance 2013 et cette
mesure finalement abandonnée vous avez
participé le medefin à ce que cette
mesure finalement soit retirée comment
ça s'est passé
un petit peu en fou avec votre reportage
quand toute la CPME a fait beaucoup
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ils ont déclare
plateau je cite leur déclaration
avec nous seul la voix de la négociation
privilégiée contre vents et marées par
la Confédération représentative des PME
donc la CGPME a permis d'obtenir ses
résultats dans l'intérêt de l'économie
française au bénéfice de ceux qui
prennent des risques pour créer de la
croissance et de l'emploi cette
déclaration vous n'êtes pas d'accord
de remettre les choses en place
aujourd'hui sur le fond la CGB CGPME est
d'accord avec nous et Laurence Parisot
discute avec Jean-François Roubaud nous
partageons le même avis maintenant sur
le combat il n'était pas signataire avec
les autres mouvements ils ne sont allés
que d'une seule voix préconise alors les
robots préconisent alors entre
négociations et collaboration vous savez
quelquefois la frontière peut être ténue
et justement moi je trouve que la CGPME
a manqué un peu de combativité alors ils
annoncent une pétition où ils auraient
eu 20 000 signataires nous on a quand
même écrit 122 000 courriers et les
entrepreneurs de Medef quand on s'est
mobilisés parce que moi j'en ai essayé
un peu assez qu'on nous dise toujours le
Medef c'est le CAC40 je fais je suis
patron du ménage en musique je suis une
PME
90% j'ai plus d'adhérents de PME que
dans la gpme des Yvelines pour un
intérêt mais quand il raconte qu'il est
le vecteur qui se sur l'entreprise c'est
un peu agaçant c'est un peu la gastro
parce que nous nous battoirs nous sommes
d'accord on intérêt commun mais ce petit
cocorico solitaire alors qu'ils sont
dans leur coin bon voilà
gestion concernant cette nouvelle banque
publique et d'investissement promesse de
campagne du candidat François Hollande
pour je cite garantir le financement des
petites et moyennes entreprises et des
entreprises innovantes fragilisées par
cette période de crise elle doit avoir
le jour début 2013 comment cette mesure
est-elle perçue au medeferez je vais
vous demander d'être bref puisqu'on est
très pris alors le temps je vais essayer
de bref c'est certainement on accueille
bien c'est une bonne mesure tout ce qui
peut être une aide est une bonne mesure
toutefois c'est un peu le flou quand
même quand j'entends notre ministre qui
nous dit que ce des prêts pour les PME
qui seront innovantes de secteurs
stratégiques d'avenir
définir qu'est-ce que c'est quand on me
dit accompagner tout au long de
développement et les aider à soutenir
l'innovation alors après un c'est quoi
une PME qu'est-ce qu'une qu'est-ce
qu'une PME quels sont vraiment les actes
vous attendez de voir
c'est bien je vais pas bouder c'est si
des êtres sont devenus pour nous
soutenir prenons-les c'est bien voilà
l'info en plus ça présente l'info en
plus de cette chronique éco du jeudi 25
octobre